hallo mein name ist luke wusstet ihr
schon dass mein name luca ist herzlich
willkommen die heute zu einem neuen
video und ich hab mir gedacht wie
alabama wieder mit dem murphy bord
deswegen befinden wir uns hier in skype
keyboard oder erkläre ich mal wieder
ganz kurz und zwar bei dem murphy bord
geht es darum dass wir mit einer person
schreiben die gar nicht existiert das
heißt es wir keine freunde haben weil
wir nicht mit normalen beschreiben
dieser person what if kong crafter bosse
princess und dann zeigt er mir wie ich
als prinzessin aus den würde das quasi-
der sinn der website so als kurzfassung
jetzt gerade da sehen wir hier schon den
chat verlauf von den letzten malen
eingeblendet und ich habe mir jetzt
wieder die besten kommentare vom letzten
mal rausgesucht die ich jetzt ja
schreiben werde einer der top comments
letztes mal war what if kong crafter
bosse gut youtuber das heißt wir
schreiben das jetzt einfach mal und
schauen ob der murphy botter irgendwie
du das kann ich leider nicht ein geben
weil das gar nicht funktioniert ich kann
allerdings eingeben roger kong kraft
aber aus youtube und dann versuche ich
jetzt mal dass der mini zeigt wie ich
als als youtuber aussehen würde das ist
da hab ich mit bismarck stellt zum glück
sieht das überhaupt nicht gut aus wie
ich als youtube aussehen würde also ich
meine die frage war was konkret youtuber
also von wegen sollen hater sagte jos
schreibt mal was wäre wenn du gute
youtuber wärs aber das geht ja nicht
deswegen kommt dass youtube sich ihre
was soll es denn überhaupt darstellen
eine andere sache die mir ebenfalls
darauf geschrieben wurde war what if
kong kraft davos julien denn das war
auch irgendwie top kommen vom letzten
video deswegen glaube ich dass da mal
eingegeben und wir schauen uns jetzt mal
an wie cool
duca also dass ich also das ist ich sehe
unfassbar hübsch aus hier können wir
übrigens auch jetzt mal wieder in die
kommentare schreiben was ich dem airport
im nächsten teil fragen soll also
schreibt in die kommentare
frag ihn mal j
angela merkel watts osama bin laden oder
irgendwie sowas also dann kann ich dann
frage ich den markt das das nächste mal
und eine chance das teuer ich glaube
habe verstanden was ebenfalls sehr auf
gefragt wurde war what if kong kraft
aber auch ukulele deswegen drückt jetzt
einfach mal enter schickt das an den
murphy bot er haut wieder seinen
komischen smileys raus und das ich dass
das ist da dam das ist ich als ich habe
jetzt mal worte wo kalibers congo after
eingegeben und da kommt diesmal als
kicker willst du mich schicken was ist
denn das für eine scheiße murphy bot das
ist das ist irgendwelche komischen
drahtseile in meiner schnauze drin ich
werde mal geschrieben wird kompakter
voßkuhle und nicht obwohl er nie
vielleicht findet er dann irgendwie ein
anderes bild und dann zeigt er mir
nämlich dass genau das gleiche an selbst
wenn ich wollte von craft aber so
kollege ein gebe also nicht cool
elizondo kollege kommt wieder dieses
bild hier also ich weiß nicht was was es
damit auf sich hat mit dieser das ist in
ordnung es ist sitzt nicht dass sich da
was gegen hc strache die wird dich
vielleicht mal paletten oft gewünscht
war auch what if kontrabass appelrath
deswegen ruhig da anfang auf der bühne
auch gleich einfach mal sonst mal wieder
rein schicken oder dann können wir mal
reagiere der motherboard sieht genau wie
wir das finden mach du heilige tolle sie
ich kacke aus deswegen boniface at
upgrades körper und ich sehe also ich
bin ich sehe weiß ich sehe wunderschön
aus lotte auf youtube.com crafter weil
wir jetzt ja schon das komplette video
irgendwie mit youtube voll hatten und
meinem schritt hier frage ich mich falls
jetzt kommen würde wenn ich wollte mit
pries irgendwie steht youtube in diesem
programm nur für irgendwann mädel was
beauty shop macht oder ich mache jetzt
mal sollen
traurigen smiley und jetzt weiß er dass
ich das nicht mochte award der kann das
dann verändern ich habe jetzt einfach
noch mal einige what if kongress apparat
und wenn ich jetzt wieder mal so mache
heißt es ja der change das foto das
heißt wir haben diesmal mit als mischung
von crafter und apa red ich bitte euch
das ist noch schlimmer als das von
vorhin ich habe wieder mit dem traurigen
smiley reagiert und jetzt kommen die dga
es ist hässlich guckt euch das mal
anders ist doch also es ist es ist
wunderschön
es ist wunderschön ich hab mal wieder
mit einem traurigen smiley reagiert und
deckt motherboard sagt wieder hier so
eine idee und wahrscheinlich bin ich das
als upgrade oder ich würde sagen da
dieses foto er jetzt halt echt überhaupt
nicht mehr und überhaupt nicht abo
ähnelt alter [ __ ] war der klatsche laut
ich bin an dieser stelle das video wenn
euch die videos gefallen würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freund schaffen wir
40.000 likes für nächsten part ich weiß
nicht 40.000 das realistisch oder ist
das zu viel ich habe überhaupt keine
ahnung schreibt mir unbedingt in die
kommentare so sachen wie what is lukas
usb hub oder what if iphone los
krankhafter ich war keine ahnung dann
suche ich mir davon die beste sachen
raus und stellt die dena flott im
nächsten video und dann sehen wir uns
auch im nächsten video wieder so